you're like you're stealing from me
i don't know gareth i would rather you
put it on something that i would rather
you put on that oh you have the tent too
taking away something taking away his
wood so he doesn't have any of that
he still has it though you want a pizza
what kind of pizza i like trash pizza
man i like pizza hut
no i mean that that's clearly what we're
getting
what type of
uh toppings i like everything except for
mushrooms i mean not mushroom other
masters olives i just don't like olives
like it doesn't matter to me what about
you hans
sausage you like sausage
i like pepperoni green peppers mushrooms
i don't know
whatever you guys decide
my turn yes
seven
wow
i'm gonna i'm gonna be a dick
yeah
that's not only but also foolish
wait that's oh yeah i'll put him back
it's not foolish because you have no act
oh i guess you could get a
you could get access to it by getting
two wood
but yeah i mean it's a 12 so you're only
covering up whenever a 12 shows up yeah
but you don't you have no access to
brick now if anything you could have
done the tin and that would have hurt me
and him
and he could have still just robbed him
oh no he got a city already
you son of a [ __ ]
cities are better than another
settlement
yes they are because you get two of the
same number yeah two of the ones that
you picked first like whenever you build
another settlement it's just like
it's probably not as oh because the
first numbers that you picked
but i didn't
i didn't pick the best numbers for
myself
i was looking at more where i'm going to
expand to
nine
say we want to trade a wood for a
stone you're gonna give me stone i need
a stone
once you give me you give me wood no
no i don't nope nope hey
do you want it
no
no okay
is it recording now yeah hello people
so reg how do you like uh being in
austin
i
love it i went to l.a recently
yeah for uh for a comedy competition
and
i'm so happy i'm in austin people here
are chill yeah la people are mean
you being serious yeah i mean they're
not real humans
they're just
struggling little rats
it's very true i noticed that
i'm done i noticed that about them um
they seem the comedians seem like
they're they're just like
over the top acting
when they're on stage like they're
trying to they're doing it for like
acting right over acting
yeah they're not like just doing jokes
they're like i don't know it just seems
doesn't seem it seems fake
because everything in california is fake
that's the whole thing there it's
everybody's face i don't think it's
everywhere who wants sheep
for what rockers wheat
i want
rock or wheat no i need rock wait let me
see if i have any access to sheep i
don't all right now i lived in san diego
for two years thanks who's the worst
people everyone out there has this
really weird mentality
san diego
oh san diego is so nice i call it the
rat race
here's the rat trap you can get
comfortable here
and then out there everybody's just kind
of like
no one accepts me because no everybody's
trying to conform
well it's a very competitive city it's a
big city people are revalued devalued
um yeah i got that wheat right back
and when people are like really
uh stressed out then they turn into like
the most base version of themselves
isn't that interesting they were
watching uh
a south korean show squid games yeah
i wasn't watching it because i can't
watch stuff like that
i need to stop like in those situations
you find out who
what you really are
like
yeah if you're putting a life or death
center it's like oh are you a good
person or not there's no faking it
so um but don't you think that most
people are pushed into being bad people
because of their circumstances and just
because you do something bad in a
stressful situation doesn't really mean
you're a bad person right
it's like do you think so no ghetto
yeah i mean
you're not judged by how you respond to
the most stressful situations but how
you respond in your life and what kind
of situations you put yourself in you
keep yourself from those situations
yeah because you think about like
in the fully done
yeah well unless anybody wants to trade
for a stone does anybody have a stone
that they don't need i need a stone i'll
give you a
whatever i don't have stone
yeah i mean nothing from you because you
like to think you would do the right
thing like if you're really good at
surviving in those stressful situations
where you're killing people you're
probably not the nicest cashier
[Laughter]
maybe that's a better skill to work on
than
trying to knife someone murder someone i
guess so
that's uh
yeah
that's true i mean yeah i know what
you're saying because like uh
uh yeah like i mean uh
like if you anyone can be nice when it
doesn't matter but it's easier to be
nice whenever do you really care about
your peep the people that you love and
are you capable of loving and
are you able to sacrifice yourself for
the greater good
eight hell yeah baby i mean don't you
think that you would die if it meant
like
yeah people that you love that survive
because that's where they because you
think about like
in the world two and stuff you're like i
would be a good person i would not
like
be on the bad team but then you're like
well they're going to kill your family
so like it's like oh yeah that changes
everything they're going to hurt people
well i mean have you watched like those
videos of the nazis getting shown like
what they did in concentration camps
like
they after the war they showed them what
was going on and like they had no
[ __ ] clue
most of them were like
[ __ ] mortified by what they were
doing but also like the nazi guards too
that were at the concentration camps
they didn't really
have any like it was after the war they
were like this is [ __ ] terrible like
they couldn't they but they kept going
along with it yes just little by little
it was my turn was it seven or no eight
you're done
yeah i mean
four they didn't know but they were a
part of it so
isn't that bad
shouldn't we
be aware you get caught up in your
time
people don't know how much it's just
like you can't see the future
yeah like
maybe in the future people will be like
i can't believe you supported that guy
he ended up killing 500 000 jews
yeah that's not that's really not cool
you know
i was listening i forget who it was it's
on podcast they said they had a
uh a nazi rally at
what's that big theater not the big
theater in new york city madison square
garden yeah is that did you hear that
yeah
it's a bunch of nazis
in america like a big picture of george
washington
what
yeah you haven't seen it no pleasure
that was like their [ __ ]
wait klossowitz
or uh
i guess it was jre with jim and jim
gavigan and joe
yeah i mean america had a fashion has a
fascist movement
we like the idea of like one guy one one
person yeah
just ruling over everything and just
being really strong
look at that
that is odd george washington it's
packed that's our idol that's who we
worship when we go full crazy
we're like what the [ __ ]
that's our idol that's who we are
how do they do that it looks like a
hologram how did they get there well
they're all about the old and they're
like the old shall be the awesomest and
we shall make everyone worship the old
and we will maintain the way things are
now and make it and not one of them has
ever read a book
apparently like what the [ __ ] was george
washington outwardly racist or something
or were they just no he just represents
the old way of doing things and like the
people that were there the longest or
whatever but but george washington was
still better than the king probably
right yeah like back then he would have
been like a
radical person probably yeah but now
he would be he's not that no he'd be
conservative but back in the day he was
probably very very radical yeah they're
like you don't want to worship the king
but god made him the king you don't want
to worship the inbred
king who's been in bread i think you're
better than
congratulations
are you done oh yeah [ __ ] i'm getting
distracted by our conversation are you
not gonna buy anything oh wait let me
see uh does anybody want some wheat
a wheat for something
no no gareth no
uh no shoot none of us had over seven
cars either right
or you get me
what'd you roll too wheat what did you
roll
uh
i forget bro
i do i honestly don't remember
we're doing like fall 18 things at once
right now
how was your trip to new york city
[Music]
i know but this is actually on in person
this is actually recording now none of
those country folk have been to the big
city i've been a victim i've been to big
city once you go [ __ ] yourself sick
bridge i haven't been to the big city
you haven't you think you're special oh
you're just talking about how your
mother lived there i'm also a country
folk yeah no where are you
where's your hometown this is my home
boston austin's my house because you're
like the only og here
there's like a few of you guys there's a
few of us but yeah pretty much man
so
when you're growing up it was a lot
smaller city yeah it was complete
me uh no two weeks wait no i don't want
it
no
sorry
who wants this
yup
wait
do you have two
i do do you have two one yeah
i'll do it
okay i don't know why
yeah don't do it
oh that was kind of stupid
i was very oh well
i got some stuff i needed to go rage ah
[ __ ] now you see everything i have
that's all right we're having a good
time
you guys blocked me off here pretty hard
nine
oh
i got wood anyways
all right
do you see this guy get scalped
what's the talking about he's five
to bill
how would he get scout by the tag the
attack
jaguar in front of him scalped him yeah
he's caught him and his claws are like
knives oh that's terrible i don't want
to see that
where was where was he
india
are they so many people in india it
probably happens once every year
why is that why does it happen more
because there's just so many people
i don't know so we somebody once said
hey you don't think it's happened it's
happened in china
yeah that's probably true
all right dude
so we should just get a combo i mean how
hungry are you right now dude 20 bucks
gets this i'm not that hungry
are you gonna
roll i did and i end my turn
i built this road
six seven [ __ ]
seven uh-huh i have to get rid of half
my cards
wait a second
oh no
i'm mad i thought i had it dang it
okay hans
what'd you buy nothing i had to get
ready to have my cards you have seven
nine two
six
oh you have your
six
there's
no brick
but you have the
wood port
yeah
i snapped on it early
[Music]
i might build here
as your plan
in the desert
yeah
it's a good number so
there you go and once you've already
eaten
yeah
eight yeah baby
that's good
i said that every time
i just keep repeating myself i'm like
old man
salam's
do you can i see the um
oh
my god
oh jesus
yeah what are we watching salmon
spawning
what's that
it's when they're at the end of the life
cycle
and they come here to the river they
live in the ocean they come into the
river they drop all their eggs and then
they die
what and then their babies are hatching
they just kind of swim around
yeah until they die not to die yeah
that's why they're all rotting and [ __ ]
they're like red
yeah this is sad
it's a cycle of life
i don't like this like this
you're in it
where
where's this located it says uh
the northwest
can't they like catch them and eat them
are you gonna pass the dice
canada's fraser river five
hey
well
f5
i'm making a settlement
correct
correct
all right
11.
finally
wow that paid off right away
did you get the two wheat too
wow thank you
thank you what are you picking up
eleven's good for me nice
ah don't touch the board
it's uh fragile do you guys watch
football
dude this week was incredible
it was the best weekend failure
[Music]
you just saw us do that
was that right
you want it back for rock
uh
no
okay i'm gonna be a dick oh you just
damn
ron's gonna lead with five
i pulled one of those earlier today
and i got five i put a i said anybody
got any brick and somebody had five
and i took all of them and i had like
seven wood and then i got longest road
i am my turn [ __ ] you hans
hey god have mercy on your soul you got
three
i got i got the wheat right back what
eight oh there we go
oh you pushed it
eight six
um
you want that brick still
no me yeah no we
i have weight you want weight no
i have so
much seven
five six
five three points
first of all
and han says five
um i'm gonna see it from rich
that's how you do it
yeah
we have we have some trouble sometimes
when i play
like people get their feelings here and
then they hold them in their hands
tightly
that's how you guys play
yeah it gets it gets pretty intense
children
so you guys bought your own katan thing
yeah it's it's expensive yeah they're
like 50 bucks yeah like 60 50 60 bucks
i can't do anything
uh wait wait wait does anybody want to
trade for a stone i need a stone
i got brick
i trade for sheep yeah
oh [ __ ] just kidding
i just realized i can't build a
settlement anyways
here you go wait wait
yeah do it dude i can't i can't because
i can't i need i need to make two roads
no it's pointless this doesn't help me
at all
five
ah you got me with that one
oh [ __ ] you hot
uh how does everybody feel about um
did you put that
on a pizza
i'm not a fan
okay
what about you rich no no no no no
actually i've never had it but
you're like i'm not [ __ ] going there
no hawaiian's like my favorite pizza
i don't want i mean we can go there if
we want but
we can go there it's not that hard to
take off but it seems like the wrong
thing to put on a pizza
i mean it's sweet people have a lot of
strong
strong opinions about yes nice strong
opinions about pineapple and pizza
i like pineapples separate
i love pineapple it's really good with
bacon and ham like it's just good report
on your pizza
also like roasted red peppers on there
too french
maybe some goat cheese do you hate that
damn you only have wheat
i got tons of weight i do
oh you took my cities away
shoot
10
solid
both of you
okay
so what do you think about
christie vera
eight nice lady
[Music]
yeah that's what i know her for her what
are you guys trying to do here
uh she was on the podcast earlier she
was uh today calling yeah because
i uh i let her stay in this house so
she was gonna give me a ride to the
airport but then her sugar daddy was
like i don't want you to leave i'll just
buy him an uber so then he bought me a
river to the airport
and then on the way back i was like hey
can i meet you up and give me the key
back and she was like can you come to
downtown and i was like sure but can you
give me a ride the rest of the way to
this house
she was like i guess i just can't do
stuff for you okay like this isn't like
you can't just force me to do things
okay can you give the key to sam kuiper
then she's like fine and then she gave
it to me i was like thanks for nothing
that is uh
yeah that's pretty accurate
you helped you yeah yeah you have it you
helped her out by giving her a place to
stay yeah i mean she did help me out by
giving me a ride to the airport from
that one dude
but then also it's like
she would have she only helped you
partly
yeah
oh wait you can help me out you went to
the airport today i shouldn't expect
that no sunday oh you got back yeah
you got more trips planned um yeah
anyone have
wow you got tons of wait wait you didn't
have to get rid of half your cards
no it's a six
whenever i wrote this did i wrote seven
i was like no no
i rolled a seven and i put it on there
anyone have uh you have to get rid of
half your cards anyone want rock
and have brick
or sheep
you don't want sheep
you don't want rock
sheep or brick no
what about for a week
i don't know i don't trust you you're
already at six yeah i do not trust
six isn't that great to be honest we can
still score
two four six eight who do we appreciate
um
what the [ __ ]
why did you say that i don't know that's
our scores
guess who's gonna be appreciate just so
emotionless
okay sorry
cheese it up
cheese it up
ah she was away for a while she wasn't
here
it's definitely interesting
um i don't feel like talking about it
[Music]
it doesn't seem healthy
yeah
so um what do you think about kill tony
it's awesome
dude it's been going great you've been
killing it
do you like that i'm on it
oh that's awesome i think it's very
inspiring too it's like hey look what
can happen
yeah for personality
less like robot autistic guy
you're not giving yourself enough credit
that's a it's a great personality and
you are a hundred percent honest
all the time
and that's what makes it great
because
if you were close like if you were
afraid to tell personal stuff it
wouldn't work
yeah i mean that's all i have to offer
so yeah but a lot of people are like
afraid to say stuff and it's like it's
not going to work
yeah
i mean
you're not afraid of how you come off
yeah you can't worry about that
dang it
this isn't going great
uh anybody
trait and nobody has brick
right nobody has broken no
no that was so aggressive
he over enunciates
everything that's how they taught him to
speak in uh the kkk's class
last few minutes
this last recording i over enunciate
things
nice last recording they didn't have a a
guest and i really enjoyed it
it was awesome dude sometimes i feel
like the guest actually hurts the vibe
yeah
ron white
oh
man
that's all right though
i didn't get up so like i want to get up
on runs that's one of my favorite
it's a legend have you done shows with
him
yeah
is he chill
yeah he's nice
he's like every the person that everyone
wants to drink with like
yeah he's like but he doesn't drink
anymore he's like my one of my favorite
comedians
so he's been doing the same bits since
you hans [ __ ] you for
since the 90s
but they're still hilarious even if you
heard him before hunter rule of four
okay
yeah um
definitely he's just one of my all-time
favorites
i love to death everything about him is
great i think last time i did this
podcast we talked about him really he's
all right how long has he lived here
wow a long time yeah i mean he's from
texas he's lived in austin forever is he
from where did he come up he's from like
the middle of nowhere texas paris texas
but he came up in houston are you done
he was up in houston around the area did
you did you already roll you rolled a
four i rolled a four yeah and i'm done
yeah i uh he was part of the texas
outlaws wasn't he
i don't know i'm not seven
nice
well my last strategy didn't really work
so we'll try a new strategy
we'll take away the wheat and hans did
you do that take away stone
he has two access to stone exactly
that's stupid i got some stupid things
anybody want sheep
or
sheep or
brick
are you laughing at my disability
yeah
are you done yes
yes i am laughing at your disability
disabilities are funny eleven
oh i don't even need that much rig
oh i forgot to pick up my wheat last
time dang it
idiot
can i go back and get it
live all right who's your favorite
person that you've met
joe rogan
yeah
makes sense checks out it makes sense i
really like joe rogan he's a nice guy
how would you know oh yeah he was kind
of a i was like
i was on kill tony 500 he was kind of a
dick to me but i think he was high and
drunk
that was a crazy episode
yeah it's like
[ __ ] am i ever going to get called up on
this show
did you go to it were you outside
that was it
that was in the beginning
are you done
yes sir
mm-hmm
six
you were you were set up perfectly for
everything to happen
because you were you've been doing it
long enough you had
material ready
yeah so you can shoot up um i have
entirely too much stuff anybody want
wheat
yeah fur what are you gonna
i don't need bread uh sheep
i don't need that either um wood yeah
nah
too weak
for one wood yeah okay
okay
um
oh my god please roll a seven brick
for you want a brick for another board i
don't have a wood
and you have you want to
now
i remember lucas mccray got called on
500. yeah he did i don't think he's been
up since
how does he show up he signs up every
now and again he doesn't
sign up that off he did really well and
then brian redmond kept booking him on
the secret show yeah he got he's one of
the few people that consistently
consistently gets booked from doing and
kill sonny sat
yeah
he i was there the first time he
did the
secret show and he killed
really hard
damn rich you got a lot of brick man i
know you want some
you should probably move your hand out
of the way of the camera though oh can
you see it yes
you're like i know
you want some
uh no
you don't i know everything in your hand
now though
you don't have any access to bricks it's
funny
it was cheating you need it you need the
brick
come on take my brick
[Music]
break a wee and a sheep
this is like playing
this is like the
damn oh well guys if you need any
thing
oh no
he's at eight well that's all the more
you can get with
god city it hans [ __ ] you digiornos
did your know
yeah really you're gonna go with this
red baron i don't know there's i don't
know brands very well
seven [ __ ] you guys remove all your
cards damn it
you're a dick
f4
i got you one roll
five
all right
i'm gonna move this rod
here
spread them
okay
so what did you think about the mics
tonight
oh awesome they were really good tonight
i bombed
terribly hard that's too bad
it's fine i had a pretty good set at the
the buzz mill i thought
i got like good chuckles all around
chuckles
a solid chuckle
just one juggle you do anything tonight
no i stayed inside all day are you done
yeah it's like you're afraid of the sun
yeah
uh nine i mean it's good to do that to
reset everything
i mean you were traveling and stuff you
probably hard last week
yeah it was good to rest
i gotta do something good to hang out
man
gone for a week i was like damn hans is
gone can't play catan at 12 o'clock at
night
you get something to go to bed like a
sane person
i'm tired of doing this i'm tired of
making roads i just want to make cities
i should probably charge my phone as far
running out of batteries
close to getting longest road i don't
have neil young died
no
he just took his music off of spotify
he did yeah
i don't
damn that sucks i love neil young why
are they beefing
that's awesome
oh
the vaccine stuff
yeah
spotify is being good though
that's proper wording well i mean
who are you gonna go with the guy that
has like 200 million active followers
are the dude that has 10 probably
that are dying constantly neil young is
an incredible artist
there's no denying that his fan base is
40 plus years old you know let's get
sing me in one of his songs
can can they even hear gareth dude crazy
hard dude you don't know neil young
i'm not going to sing you a neil young
song
just sing it acapella
i got a tinder match
are you uh
did you get any tinder matches with all
those kissing pictures no no
yeah
i hear that hinge is just the [ __ ] in
new york what number is it six
anyone want wood
i don't know
yeah what what for do you have wheat no
yeah johanna
oh no i don't know if i should have done
that
i regretted it instantly
well that was bad what oh it's just a
div oh hopefully don't trade him do not
trade him shh this game is going so fast
we're gonna play another one
riley see if he wants to come
seven
seven move it
how do i forget how to spell riley's
name there is
uh you need to get rid of your cards
brother
you're right yeah
all right i texted him
he said he was doing a set somewhere
before this
that was hours ago though
are you done are you stealing
waiting for him to remove his cards and
then steal from you actually give me you
can't dude
i can't you're right
whatever i'll steal from hot rodge
no
you made a circle around the bricks
i know
i don't know what i want i have longest
road too oh yeah
god damn it
now you're gonna steal one of my cards
playing my victory point
just so you can pull somebody don't look
as bad so you can pull it up
and just pull this up a little bit
all right i'll give it
an extra
are you gonna move it again yeah oh is
that why you put it there so you can
move it right back
smart that's kind of shitty
yep
but it's not on you you need to play
that card when it's on your earphone
turn i have my turn i'm kidding i don't
care
eight no
no
no
eight i've been really uh eight i've
been really into comedy right now
like it goes in waves i've been writing
and like performing awesome and i'm
re-inspired oh
i started a job at a horse farm
yeah tell me about your horse farm job
dude yeah so like i get up at like
yes i get up at like six and i go to the
farm work from like seven to eleven and
i come home and i write
get ready and then
do my jokes
just gonna move this have you been
writing much
yes
no no not me
where would i put it
six
i really need threes and
uh covered up
if i get eleven six eleven and then uh
eleven nice that's a good number for me
damn it [ __ ]
you got an 11-2 gareth i know
i wish i had a port
all i got is a sheet port that someone
does no good
i wish i wish i wish
i wish i wasn't a fish
uh let's see here
you are jewish i'm watching i'm reading
the book
the comedians right now have you guys
ever read it
thank you
yeah no i haven't
but i have watched um
the show
or stand up or worse stand up comics
whatever on uh hb or on
show time with
um
it's got
the dude
are you from
i'm not done i'm building a city
and
it's got what is his name montez i
always forget what's so funny i saw him
at the cave
what's the point of this
to build a city
know your story like get on with you
it's a really good show okay
but no
i was reading about the stand-ups and
it's talking about like
vaudeville and all the different times
time periods and i think austin will be
one of those time periods that they
write about
and hans kim will be one of the people
that write about like this dude maybe
i'll be the one writing maybe you'll be
the one yeah maybe usually it's
from a non-comedian though i think
right something i'm gonna get y'all
is it are you done yes
you got
five points four
[Applause]
how does that keep happening
oh my
sorry i think in the future we'll all
figure things out or things will be
figured out it's what life's about the
ups and the downs
does anybody like to trade wood
does anybody have wood
no
no thank you nobody
two three four five six seven
i think you can get everything at once
things won't be as nice if you get
everything at once right or unless
you're just really rich
but like are they happy awesome
i don't know
eight if you're having really good h
good for you
i think it's more important if you have
good friends people you love
and people like to hang out with
yeah that's the most important part
seven
i've got hit with this a lot
hey look christopher castro gave us ten
dollars and send money for the booze
pool for bucket comics thanks for coming
guys i love you guys
well thank you thank you castro are you
related to fidel awesome dude
you're making fun of him oh sorry
hey [ __ ] you i'm a comedian that's what
i do
that's right
i i gotta check my phone
who else do you think is coming did
anyone like a tan group nobody responded
oh i was going to respond and sam yes
so then maybe
sam lopez
nobody responded
okay
how do you feel about sam lopez
i think she's great
me too she's awesome she seems super
nice yeah as far as i've ever had
uh
who's up well i mean riley said he was
down earlier what the [ __ ] i'm still
going i'm trying to figure out i'm just
gonna do it at 10 because you guys came
too early
there's two people that donated ten
dollars right yeah
who's the other person
have a beer on me hans killing it keep
it up my favorite autistic comedian
working today is that a joke about
austix
went down no [ __ ] i should have brought
some
tell riley to bring himself
um you should have ordered beer too
can't i order beer
what would you order beers from you
didn't order pizza no you gave up
well everybody else was like so adamant
about not being hungry so i was like
this whole [ __ ] would anybody like to
trade trying to eat lose weight right
now um
this for wood
someone didn't move the robber
that was me yeah it's too late
it is too late
that sucks it's too late because it just
hurts me
yeah
you're taking advantage of me
all right nine
hold on
one two three four five six
oh no wait wait i didn't go i think that
person oh no they're ten dollars i just
saw it
i have disappeared plan can you do that
i'm going to move it here
from range
that's [ __ ] great
i always steal a weight
that's what i get mostly
nine come on six
yeah no you just covered it up
son of a [ __ ]
oh no hans is gonna get another night
card but you can't play it this round
oh you have something in your hand
oh he has a victory point
this is no good guys
i'm a commentator for this we should
have a commentator
so this is like oh no he's won
yeah i [ __ ] hate hans wait you did
that for a
development development i guess so if
you're gonna
get largest nine [ __ ] you nice
oh i've got to make moves
is that the only nine we where's the
other nine
oh i get another there yeah where's that
oh right here
oh my god
just this one no both yes
both
11.
okay
garrus you want to put over resources
together
i can't stop him two four six eight
if that's a night card
there's nothing we can do
oh he's just a big [ __ ]
um i have how many do i have two
four
two four
five
seven
yep two so i can get to nine that's not
eight [ __ ] i'm doing so bad this game
um
i'm taking my time because i'm afraid
you're gonna win on this round
oh i just say that what
i mean there's nothing else i can do
should we invite some chicks yes
please
the chicks hate katan they do
yeah they do we don't have to play
guitar
except for christina oh she loves
skating
he should have specified oh what do you
want to do let's just say we're doing a
podcast
invite them over there surprise
these girls that are contaminated
comedian girls or these comedian girls
that you're talking about fighting over
either or
do we know anybody else that's not a
comedian
no really
i mean
there's a handful you have i have to
wait to play this right
yeah
uh your turn i win
11 points i [ __ ] hate you dude
that makes sense i have two rounds
six more points than i did
two four cheating dude what the [ __ ] are
you doing all right look at the footage
all right let's start again right away
look at the footage i'm gonna roll it
back just
i swear to god i'm gonna watch it
i want to rewatch all of this to make
sure you just didn't cheat
strip poker this isn't strip poker
don't don't pay attention to them no if
you give us money we appreciate you wait
should we read them i really need money
for people
damn pizza sounds good hey we need money
for pizza i feel i want to order a pizza
i just don't want to waste the food
because it's a [ __ ] eating grin does
that mean he eats ass
luckily we have refrigerators
here we go more plates so yeah i can
just give you the rest of the videos
what is rich crazy
hans your thoughts on rich crazy asians
it's a shitty movie but it's fine
hans said quit talking about his parents
david my parents they talk like this
dude that's racist
that's why it's so funny right now
it's a little trick i can do it
anytime
very very funny
you like that that remember that girl
that was on kill tony that was the
opener i don't want to talk [ __ ] on
people [ __ ]
yeah i'm sure you're probably really
nice people this person says gareth we
love you
david oh that's nice
yeah i appreciate you all very much um
what else are we saying stop being so
damn messy taylor
way to go hans winter
hans is allowed to do
that hans is allowed to do that voice um
i don't know where's the bourbon gareth
do these people know you
they're talking about you like
i don't know how you didn't get ads
driving
that was what you were drank all the
whole [ __ ] we drank like the same amount
just like got obliterated and we were
just like what what's going on
hey guys if you donate money i'll take a
shot for every ten dollars we don't have
any alcohol don't tell them it'll just
be water
no i don't know a lot of
the greatest hey hans i have a question
gareth what up from a town in san diego
last time i saw han's
a-town in san diego
what is that anthony
that's i think that's my boy dude he ran
we used to run a deep uh uh deep water
he water fishy
fishing boat yeah yeah
[ __ ]
we can talk [ __ ] on gareth now
hey yo my name is ridge
should we do a little commercial break
yeah what's a commercial break so we
have a break for commercial purposes
oh what's your commercials
royalty-free music oh
this what do you think i should play i
think i should just look up some ads
yes just play ads so then you make money
on it
maybe
i can't believe there's people actually
watching it's crazy
can they hear us still yeah
this is so awesome
hello
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and we're live
welcome back to the podcast we're just
gonna be
playing a little more katan for you guys
and my name is hans kim
uh coming to you live from austin texas
and this here is rich hershberger he is
a member of the amish community
i left
i was uh
i was like eh
i don't want to marry my cousin hans are
you about to scratch the mic
make everybody horny right now what
scratch oh with the
mickey
yeah it sounded like one of the you
sounded like one of those hosts from uh
whatever that shit's called
there was something else i was looking
at
okay i'm gonna roll first here see where
who goes first
eight
all right the only thing that went right
for me last time was the roll well i
don't know if it did though because you
didn't win
that's what i'm saying it was the one
thing all right so um
is anyone else coming
nobody's answered me who else got eight
you got eight yeah i got it we both got
eight so
you can roll first re-roll no
oh my god that's how you don't pick up
the box yeah you're right
six
six
five
there you go i don't need all right you
go first sorry
oh i didn't even look at the board yet
uh
eight two three nine six
three four two three what numbers are
bad six nines
this is a really even board
even steven
there's
two eights on the sheep you don't need
sheep that much yeah just a little too
easy
i'm gonna do that i'm gonna go right
here
seems like a good place to go
which way should we swing it doesn't
matter
um
yep
just gonna do a little placement and
then now we're gonna go
you like this shape
i was just glad you didn't pick that
spot
uh
oh i guess
i got two more dots than you i know but
is it how is it helpful though yes yes
you think so that is somewhere have you
looked up about it
so uh who else can we invite do you
still hang out with dalen mendoza
uh no i haven't hung out with him a
while because he's gay yeah do you think
he's gay
yeah
yeah uh he he's uh why do we just talk
um
doesn't he tune into this sometimes
isn't it funny when that he went up on
the dating show
oh yeah
i don't know why that's funny can you
explain to me why that's fine because
his ex was the guest on it
oh and then rachel's like i think
there's an elephant in the room nobody
brought it up
oh god
so do you think that the dating show is
a fun thing to do and that it'll be well
attended in the future
well when i went there was like 30
people there yeah it's been getting
better and better hasn't it yeah
yeah every time i've went it's been yeah
i think your interviewing skills have
gotten a lot better
thank god
thanks for um
turning on the thing that you turned off
what happened
the thing turned off because you turned
it off you uh
didn't
you unplugged it so the the camera's not
working
you're not working
oh no
this is all not working
i had to keep my what i can hear myself
in this
how can i hear myself
did i ruin everything
i don't know man i don't know what to do
anymore i [ __ ] hate you guys
[Music]
[Music]
i'm regretting my decision of where i
placed them
but you regret decisions
sure man
take a slice you're probably hungry you
wanted some pizza
i know you can't tease us with pizza
like
you didn't give me enough of a
commitment i got a bunch of i don't
knows i need a solid we said yes
rich said he was gonna eat it yeah
that's not enough of a good commitment
aren't you hungry started on the process
of ordering aren't you hungry yeah but
then i really yeah but dude i can't eat
i'm trying to lose some weight all right
like
if you if we got a whole pizza rope us
into your weird relationship with food
you say you're gonna get food [ __ ]
get it it's like a tea you can't bring a
gun out in the second act and not fire
it
yeah you can dude that's absolutely what
uh to kill mockenberg is about you know
no it's my turn
oh
why did you anyways
shut up dude why do you place them
towards each other you can't even build
shut up dude
[ __ ]
i should have said nothing don't tell me
what to do you like to have eleven i put
it dude what the [ __ ]
gary
his mom's an eleven oh you get a six too
you know what hans what is that supposed
to mean are you banging my mom dude yeah
man
my mom was like he is cute oh [ __ ] when
i said that on stage she yelled at it
yelled out
horror wait was she there
yeah oh you're not my phone we go back
to the next one too your show
were your parents in town
he's from here
oh your
that'd be cool
have you picked out who you're gonna
roast yet
no is that really happening yes
what do you mean is that really
happening i mean it seems like it's not
a real show what's gonna happen so it's
a real show
we're gonna do a roast battle
and then figure it out it's at the creek
of the tenth man why do you not think
it's a real show because the name of the
group is not a real show
really
i don't believe that
the instagram group patrick depart
changed the name to not a real show
what do i need brick and
gay
easy peasy
says patrick off of the show now
isn't it your show
yeah
now that reminds me
the camera's not working
okay
are you gonna order the pizza
yeah dude i'll order the video
where should we invite
christina has work tomorrow
i do too but
riley didn't answer me
hello
whose turn is it
are you ready to go
is your
your turn right rich
no
i already played here yeah yeah
well do you have any idea who you would
want to roast hans
yeah because i have three people that'll
want to line up
i just changed the group name back to
five
[ __ ]
five five five five five five it'll be
good
five
a little more aggressive less on the
humor more on the violence
boy
believe
nice
oh this is a tough game for brick too
yep
it didn't work out me last time for me
having all that break
it kind of worked out and then i got
right in the middle
oh [ __ ] you don't open it don't
don't open it the box stays still
four bow
nothing
oh wait yeah i got a wood
do you think that
the austin comedy scene is better than
the la comedy scene
um
yes
why i think i don't know i uh i don't
know whatever i saw i like austin a lot
better personally
um
they were i thought the comedians here
are better
they're more jokey there's more jokes
it's an important part of comedy like
a lot of the comedians they just go on
like feelings
yeah i felt this way at the bank today
and like
here there's written material and then
it's obvious people
i'm trying hard
and everyone here tries hard like
there's
there's kill tony helps
having it here
yeah is everyone's thinking about would
this work on killtown the one minute set
yeah let me write out a joke that would
work
yeah and that's the it breeds shorter
jokes too kill tony
which is good because you got to learn
how to walk yes yes exactly
like everybody seems like they're trying
to be bill burr where they're just
ranting but like trying to get the most
difficult part of comedy first
and it's and if you try to do that and
you don't get anything it's gonna be
frustrating for you because you're just
not gonna get any laughs
but if you learn how to write a joke
first and then you can turn it turn that
put that joke inside a rant
um
so i like that and the people here it
might not be quite as big but everyone
here works hard like there's probably
like 50 comedians that go to 10 mikes a
week or i don't know about 50 but like
there's a lot
and then there's probably 50 that are
there's a good scene here
five
does anybody want to trade
i got wood and wheat
[Music]
i don't think everybody has anything
anyways right yep
uh what do you how do you feel about it
two
no two one has it i'll roll again
i could just use that box
anyone want sheep
yes i rolled an eight thank you
where's the other right
you want sheep
you don't trade for don't trade what do
you want wheat or brick
yeah
wait let me see what i oh yeah yeah
that's fine um
shoot
you want to do it again
but for brick this time yeah
you want sheep
underneath you on the right there
no i want a brick
uh
i can't do it
yeah just wreck what about a sheep for a
wood
you have a wood
yeah but i don't want to trade this
sheep
you don't want a sheep mm-hmm
how do you have a total i don't need
more sheep
one two three four five six seven
uh riley said he can't right now
maybe
later go ahead gareth
five eight
eight
you need a brick wants to trade me for a
brick guys
i need brick oh we're gonna everyone's
gonna need brick
that's we're just gonna be saying that
right now yep
because you started on it
no but i used it for a wood
store
i have no idea
it just showed up in my hand do you have
it was a three year old
no no threes were rolled
i don't know sometimes i just got lucky
but it doesn't logically make sense i
don't know how i got broke
oh i traded four in for one
nine
so 99.
what's your favorite song
of all time it's a really hard one of
second generation iphone
uh
you go first
song yeah oh i'm not great with songs
what about tainted cell
soft self pink good love
i am
right now i like [ __ ] i can't remember
the name of it
there's a handful of perfect songs and i
think that there's two that i could say
like right off the bat
um this is the place fight you're upon
white stripe or the white stripes
no i did i just put in that box i'm just
switching to that box is that confusing
i can't reach my face
talking heads that's my favorite band of
all time i think this is the place it's
probably like the best song one of the
best songs ever made also um
the beatles
have a couple of them but my all-time
favorite it's gonna be my favorite's
probably
while my guitar gently weeps um here
comes the sun is a classic
such a great film
um
others well for me
what's your favorite beatles album
that's a really good question
the uh
the dung beetles
six what
the young beatles
was even [ __ ] mean dude
the second one
the one with the uh black and white and
color oh the white album
yeah the uh yeah that's right after
rubber sole with the white out
how did you do how are you doing this
what obviously you just placed it now
you just put your records out yeah in my
uh
life is probably my favorite song of all
time
i think it's a perfect song
if there is ever one man um
[ __ ]
so that's what they're seeing right now
don't you think that it's like we can
uh see anybody
build and develop nope and hold and
trade resources better in a more equal
society whereas one where there's wealth
inequality where five people have all
the money nope
but who's gonna who's gonna control it
the people who
are in that society as a group that vote
on it i think it's too
large
of a it's too big too many people
but we have the internet now 10. um
nobody the internet would help but would
that mean we'd have to vote every day on
something
like you just vote on your phone it's
like hey should we do this and it's like
well we can vote to like put in people
that are good at the job
but isn't that what we're supposed to be
doing now
well now it's just money and corporation
i think that's the issue i think that's
it yeah is that it's just controlled by
the corporations yeah and there's too
much money in politics yeah
but once people have money then they're
they're going to try to keep it yes and
they're very good at doing that yeah and
like oh wait is it your turn yes it's
hanza's turn 10. wait wait wait uh
no it's han's turn what are you doing i
know it's i just rolled i just can't do
anything you just rolled uh anybody want
to trade
you want to give up you want to rock get
rid of rock i'll just trade you
something
nobody no uh trade you uh
sheep for
wood
i shoot for a wood
how dare you
no
no
all right euro pawns
answer would you rather judge the roast
six six
maybe
yeah we have to get a panel too
still
um anyone want sheep
no
anyone want wheat
no
anyone want wood
we just want rock no
don't trust you
go ahead
11 just what i needed
yes the lemon is so good for you it's
sad oh it's so good
you needed wood
so you may want to trade and
break i need wood does anybody need
anything yeah prick
brick
um i'll do your bread for a hay
no
do you have any hay
cause
you've gotten faster
faster you should be really slow with
this game
really
like even slower than now yeah it used
to take forever
i can't imagine
okay
i think if you try really hard you can
because you were there hans all in my
turn
somewhere
[Music]
the rain
nine
niner
[Music]
all right you're a pawns
five
nice
nice
so good for me
good for me mates
who's the hardest person you've seen
crush
since being in austin
probably darian irwin on my foot
[Laughter]
yesterday on the podcast i thought you
were really fat
why was that directed was he here
yesterday no
just like i want to clip that part and
just be like
you're savage i was just making fun of
how fat you were yesterday
you're like bring them here like hey
dude look how big this look at this
i have a video to show you like it's a
little mean you know do you ever you
ever want spotify or anything
this podcast yeah not really
go ahead gareth
three
nice
[ __ ] you
nice
got another brick finally
i'm bricked up boy
no sevens have been rolled yet what are
the odds
oh we're doing
nothing i don't have
how do you not have any
salute
you having a connection
hey you know
you want hey
what do you want to give me
you know what i do need hay i wouldn't
want to trade
what do you want
um
brick
okay
done
no [ __ ] yeah
you want wood
yeah i do want a wood what do you want
to trade for it
right
no i need that brick
so i'm sorry i can't do that right now
um
wheat
no
sheep i don't know something what what
sheep sure
no no no no sheep i already have too
many sheep
well then you can trade four sheep no no
i need two sheep i need two sheep if you
want to do that
about a sheep in a rock
[Music]
somewhere
over the rainbow
[Music]
dreams that you dream of dreams really
do
[Music]
can you not sing if you're not going to
sing
sorry
behind
me
you'll find me
[Music]
do you think that's in key in tune i
thought it was yeah can you just do it
by yourself i'm a little nasally dude
i'm sorry it's just not even close
all right who's up
i'm done gareth are you done are you
done guys you're done
you're done i didn't roll the [ __ ]
three yeah i rolled it yeah i'm done
with number
four
fourth floor oh yeah dude
do you know how to play no i don't know
how to play the ukulele dude okay then
uh just sing it on your own
[Music]
somewhere
[Music]
and
the
dreams that you dream of
dreams really do come true
[Music]
saturday i'll wish upon the
[Music]
i don't know dude i don't [ __ ] know
bro all right
go ahead
i'm trying
this is pretty intense
[Music]
[Music]
seven
i have three cards i have six five cards
gareth you're a green yeah
rage you have four
yep you have four two no you have three
oh she would have taken the sheep
yeah i don't
oh now look at me i don't want to sheep
anyways
you ain't got no sheba bye
here
[ __ ]
nothing does anybody want to trade for a
wheat
you want a wheat i want a weed i'll give
you wood no i don't have it all right
i'll give you three sheep i'm sorry man
i can't do that
six six you son of a [ __ ]
it's a six right
yes
yeah he [ __ ] us
i'm mad about that
go ahead hans
when did you start playing the uke
two days ago
is it transfer from uh
the guitar
uh yeah
what
oh my god [ __ ] jesus
nice
oh wow hans
anyone want wood
no
i'll take a hay if you got it
i don't okay that's what i need so uh so
uh
nine now you got it somebody's
somebody said they enjoy the consistency
of your streaming
i'm not consistent at all i didn't do it
at all last week
just do a lot randomly
i think that's best
well i'm gonna get high
now no we don't get it
[Music]
can i have some of that not weed
that was i think a lot i think there's
this one do you have uh clips
rich roach clips
[Music]
i'm done i can't do anything i should
just save
sick
damn it i [ __ ] hate you horns
huh
one's a [ __ ]
you're up pawns
eleven oh yeah
oh yeah eleven's a rule two years
he gets an orgasm every time an 11 is
rolled
nut city dude
anyone want rock
anyone want wood
i'll take rock you have wheat or a brick
nope nobody has break what about two
wood
for one rock
no
there
nine
hans why don't you trade me that wheat
buddy boy i'm good come on man what do
you want brick
yeah i'll trade you a break for that
week
here uh one two three four five six okay
oh no we're all tied up
nope hans has only three
i'm sure he's about to win
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
that is my turn
[Music]
five
uh anywhere you want wheat
you know i'm not sheep anymore wood
no
i do a lot of trading if y'all want any
of that stuff
i don't know your [ __ ] dude
i want rock
go ahead
11.
how is this happening
it's just getting super lucky
oh i get three
stop coming
i had sex with this girl on tim or no uh
that i met at the lucky dog a couple
weeks ago
now we're all tied up
and
she wouldn't stop snoring
like she like every time she went to bed
maybe you should stop telling your
stories
thanks bud
anyway i just kind of keep banging her
because i had no other option because
they couldn't get any sleep
i felt like she was thinking the same
thing
stop coming
not the stories but thanks you [ __ ]
[ __ ] sorry dude you remembered the
lucky duck yeah how'd you meet her dude
we just started chatting it up it was
pretty great she's cute yeah she's cute
she's very cute i don't know what
happened the
faded
things have not had her glasses
yeah thanks bud
appreciate you once more
you can't all be hans kim just getting
lucky all the time
yeah i mean i kiss a lot of [ __ ]
guess what eleven
no yes no yes
this can't keep happening yes they can
it has to stop they won't
what will gareth do
gareth is gonna make a road for sure
so i'm going to get right here that
gives me the longest road no no you're
only a four oh no you're right
[Music]
oh
oh my god
so much wood
these four
you don't have it memorized
he's
slow in the head yes we know that
we're all aware
and uh we're gonna return we're gonna
we're gonna keep this moving
six oh my god damn it goodness hans how
is this not moved
i'm kind of glad i didn't move though
because i have so many
cards but i can't do anything so what do
you think about women
[Laughter]
they're the worst
oh my god would anyone like to trade
women
cows cows
for sure isn't that sort of sad cows
don't uh try to [ __ ] does anybody
take your heart would anybody like to
trade
rock leave you
i'll trade a lot of stuff for raw money
and you don't have any rock
i don't i would trade a lot of stuff for
rock you have raw
yeah you have rock
i'll trade you
okay what do you want
i want a sheep yeah or a hay i'll give
you sheep
can you give me a hay
no can you give me a hay no you have two
rock
no
yeah come on man
all right fine
wait
how about this
a wood
and
i don't have another raw because i
thought i did but i have a rock and a
wood or a rock of wood for a wooden
sheet a sheep
a rock and a wood
you'll give me a wood for a sheep and a
hay yeah done
hell yeah
you gave me two
weeks oh thanks
wow
what a good guy
that's how i roll
so do you think that um
girls have to use their [ __ ]
for
health care
why and
to survive and so they're less likely to
have sex because they need to use it
strategically to survive
so maybe if they didn't have to use
their [ __ ] to survive they could use
it for fun
how you're supposed to [ __ ] are you
talking about right now hans you sound
super [ __ ] crazy right now dude
you don't think that women have to [ __ ]
the right people to survive no i think
that's like the
the ultimate goal that nobody talks
about right like girls don't want to be
like i don't i want kids in a while
and all that right
like they're not going to say they want
that but that's the overall goal
at the end of the day that's what they
all yeah but if like in europe they're
more free about sex
they just have sex and they're they're
not like [ __ ] people for survival so
it's a lot more fun
and less like fraught with danger and
jealousy and competition
because they have health care they take
care of their people that you don't you
you're gonna be safe
well it's also completely different
there they have like ads with naked
people and [ __ ]
right that's only what i know i've heard
eleven ten
is there only one ten
two
five really good for hans
really would for hans
i'm gonna build the settlement it's good
for ridge too
[Music]
i want to get that freaking robber off
of there
oh [ __ ]
what idiot
you try to build a settlement shut up
heinz
that's so silly dude
damn it you're so silly
are you making fun of my gay voice
yeah
it's [ __ ] fruity as hell dude
did you think that ridge
is like super wound up tight so he would
if you don't bend you break so you
probably like
have a lot of gay sex
five
having a lot of gay sex
i like women
does anybody want wheat i thought you're
gonna say this anyone gay
um
yeah i want some wheat dude
you have wrong i don't i have nothing
three wheat from one rock
rock
sheep
wait
europe
china
how do you feel about the gays three
they're fine
i uh
i think that
in some ways they're the sheep
i'll just hit three four one anyone a
brick
i have brick you want water sheep
three wood
for one brick
yeah
there you go
you did all that just for a road
yeah
one two three four yeah
are you ordering the pizza
no
no i thought you said you were gonna
nine
oh
gareth gets a lot of rock
hmm
[Music]
do you really want to trade for a wheat
you want wheat i want a wheat yeah i'll
trade wood or a
i
sheet
have i don't have wheat
no no
okay
i have my turn
18
mate
[Music]
i just chugged that water
i'm going to play my night card
gareth you're ahead
i have this one
no
no let me spread them
i'm all right
it's just cbd dude
it is really yeah it's just cbd
[Music]
okay well i hope not
it is hans it definitely is it's
definitely damn that sucks
all right what a waste
yeah whatever dude
world of
austin texas
oh yeah you get to steal one of my cards
it felt a little bit hard
i really needed that actually i hate you
right now
so uh have you been talking to that oh
from what
well it's just built right here
what do you mean instead of building a
road save up because this is you you're
battling for this you're right i should
take that back can i take it back yeah
uh yeah i'm talking to her good
yeah she's a nice lady
her friend uh mastery said she's coming
into the 10th for that show
how do you know
she said she was
oh all right
you can go unless somebody wants to
trade wheat she messaged me oh matt
morgan yeah oh why are you messaging
morgan
why
11 11
no
yes
wheat wheat wheat
what scared that
six
i like this keeping track score on this
screen
yeah it's one of the perks of playing
with us we're not some bush league
[Music]
i don't even have to remember it in my
head
this is
some major leagues
what's going on what are you doing
sure look at that
it's your turn still hans
so he doesn't have wheat
i guess wheat is valuable it blocks his
most valuable resource he has no access
to wheat
so if we don't trade it with him he
can't get it rich you think you're
[ __ ] smart i don't know i'm afraid
if i put it here that wouldn't
it would block off oh you can move it i
guess not
oh you can move it because you have
ten
nothing for me but i'm gonna build a
settlement god damn it
son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yep jesus you really aren't homies you
should be a [ __ ]
you're just proving that you're you lost
the community
[Music]
how does that feel right not good
because i wanted that so then every time
i got a six and a five year old i got a
city
that you did
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um i'm gonna build a road too i think
eric's in the lead i think
garrett
stop here if
ridge
what's wrong here you know me
i only get mad when people that know me
mispronounce my name
i'm doing it on purpose i know you're
doing it on purpose
on the last day of saturday it's
upsetting
i have my turn
see blocked his wheat
nice
how does that feel gareth oh you son of
a [ __ ]
i've just realized i had that for when i
just realized they had the wood too
there so anybody want a tray of wheat
trade wheat to me
no
no one as we gareth definitely doesn't
know who we ate definitely
i would have had enough to build another
city you can go ahead
wait
just kidding
what are you doing
develop my corn
all right i already bought a development
card he said his turn
john's what's your favorite city to have
lived in
new york
austin always will be
austin
you say you like awesome better
sometimes 12.
everything has their own benefits
what part's awesome
do you like
i like that it's a nice place
i like that it's easy to live here
it's not like new york where it's hard
to live
because it's expensive
and there's parking and so many people
yeah dirty
it's expensive
is there a lot of homeless
yeah that's so cold there though i know
they sleep in the subways oh it's warm
in the subways anyone want wood
i don't know um oh wait yeah sure i'll
take some trade your wheat
for three
how many deer yeah we what do you want
for that wood wood wheat
oh you want wheat yeah i don't have
wheat i only oh i have no no at least
two no
two
two
so they sleep inside
yeah the [ __ ]
the and the police don't do anything
right i probably should have done that
really there's so many of them there's
so many of them they just move on to the
next one hopefully
um but yeah there's a lot of homeless
people and it's kind of cruel to like
arrest them for being homeless
so i don't think it happens that much
what are they gonna do anyways if you
arrest them
yeah they just go right back i don't
wanna show you something you can't do
you want wood it's a system we live in
for wheat yeah no what about
sheep
for rock or wheat no
what about wood
nah wait
you want sheep
or wood
two wood
not traded
two sheep
two sheep for one
for one rock or wheat
you have rock or wheat
i have wood i don't need one oh
um
i'll just oh you need
no i can't say that
okay
go ahead
stew hans
nine
oh yeah that's big for gareth
you said nine yes sir
anybody want to trade for some wheat or
i need a wheat or a
wood
i have wood
okay what would you like i'll give you a
sheep and a stem
for one wood a sheep and a stone for one
drink
i don't have brick
in the stone no
come on two it's two for one throw
something else in there about all right
another stone
son of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i don't you're winning this gets rid of
all my cards and i'm going to build
another city yeah i know i'm winning but
i've never won
so i know you never i've never [ __ ]
won ever never he's never won
not my wife
never not once ever i've played i have
countless games you're lying dead
serious
one time i was at nine points and i
needed one sheep to win for like 10
turns
and my friend won because he didn't
shuffle the deck and he just kept
getting three points and i was so mad
nine
again good for you and hans and
i need
a brick
y'all don't have you break no you don't
no i have four all right go ahead hans
stone now
seven
i'm at eight
oh no
how many cards you have 13
yes
six this is exactly what i needed i
needed hansa's tank right now
it's still going to make something
now you have to move the robber
me
whoever rolled the seven anyone want
wheat
i did
i rolled it anyone want wheat
anyone want wood
i want wheat
you have
rock
stone yeah or brick rock yeah i have a
stone
you wanna do it again
yeah
okay
somehow you're gonna score five points
on the
street can kill somebody without that i
would flip the table if that didn't
swear to god
like here's three victory points and uh
i'm gonna build two cities oh this is
funny somebody said
we might be experiencing history
a gareth win
that's funny
right there
has entered the chat ladies and
gentlemen
did he did he give you a ride
yeah
thank you
shout out
hey sam why are you here you [ __ ]
he said his voice was going hoarse oh
i'm sorry and i didn't mean to call you
who's i'm brand new in a loving way
what is this
he said it hey that sounds like sam
um hey are you in the group message no
what'd they say
um
how do i get to the message that i sent
you and your text message
can i copy it yeah
and send it
oh there's a bunch of people down
tell them to come over
so
i'm gonna make
are you gonna text it
okay
oh no this is frozen
i'm just frozen looking at my phone
gareth looks tired as [ __ ]
no that's just how i normally look i'm
totally okay but yeah i i'm worried
about your health buddy are you good i
never stop
yeah i mean i think my face looks a lot
better after i got that facial not
the load to my face by a gentleman but i
actually went to a really cool uh spa
place and got a treatment done on my
face
because i get these really bad bags
under my eyes from allergies oh that's
what they are yeah
this girl came up to me and she was like
did somebody punch you in the face
i was like dude no i just have fun you
have do you take my medication for your
allergies oh [ __ ] so much i take
zyrtec allegra claritin you think you
should take all of them everything yeah
because didn't you think you should just
used to
one of them if i just take it for too
long
so i have to do like one a different one
all the time and usually i'll take two
that's gary's old man rant for the day
y'all
gary's friend
i like viagra
actually mexican viagra is incredible
it's like taking a little bit of wait
whose turn is it
this is my turn
have you ever taken a mexican viagra
before no
it's called el vigro
that [ __ ] [ __ ] pat you were gonna
freak out
what's why is it why is it so much
better
um i'm pretty sure it comes with another
drug
i don't know
it might be meth i don't know
you [ __ ] like a wild animal how do you
get a hold of this uh you can get them
online man they're expensive the growers
are expensive though
it's like twenty four dollars a pill
damn but i used to live in san diego so
i could go with anthony's still here
what's up anthony uh hey tom
my boy joe
um we should we could go you could go
down to tijuana i had a friend
i would just go to tijuana and he'd get
come back across the board with so much
[ __ ]
i mean but that's just how it goes down
there
here though 24 pill
they're like this big
they're literally like they're huge
yeah it's like a suppository almost it's
[ __ ] where do you how do you take it
do you just plug back in yeah throw it
down thanks
here i'm stealing from
you
wait one two three four five six seven
eight you have eight points yep
i don't like that hans has those three
development cards just sitting there
eight points for yeah i know
he's gonna pop out
um he's gonna go from five to four i
think that's five one two three four
five
hogs have you ever had to take a viagra
before
no
you've never had you've never tried it
though never tried it no i want to i'll
get you one
what are the mexican ones you're one of
those mexican
yeah one two three four five six seven
eight nine
who's at nine oh you're at nine
no i was counting the number of dots
anyone want wood no
okay one two three four
five six i have six points oh almost
six points
eight
a couple sheep for gareth
nobody has brick huh
hey hey hey
hey hey hey
what you know about me
all right
i have my turn
[ __ ] boy popping what you know about
four four oh
yeah what does the group chat say
i have my notifications turned off
yeah me too
uh you said who's coming nobody answered
who's coming audiences
sorry
did i just
put you on blast
anybody have a break
no no
never had wheat no
um i think you do have wait
oh my god dude you son of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
just lying through your teeth
it was like a four was just rolled you
know what dude i uh i play i play by my
own rules okay
if i don't want to tell you what i have
you know what happens bridge yeah
six i have six two
oh [ __ ] you guys are getting close
you're son of a [ __ ] ridge
you're up
ah
[ __ ] dick
you've been
holding hold of huddling that all night
cuddling oh my god dude
i swear to god
i've been reading books so my vocabulary
has expanded oh i just saw a quarter of
it
i just saw the hedgehog one
this [ __ ] dude he probably has
another one too it hasn't been played
for a little while so he has eight
he has eight
watch out for this piece of [ __ ] i swear
to god dude that's how you play katana
maybe he has nine
[ __ ] hate you dude
oh [ __ ] here go ahead
why is this board so much harder than
the other ones nine
that's a lot of stone for gareth
two three four
i'm gonna play this night card
move
oh no one night card played yeah how
many can you how many can you how many
knight cards can you play in a round
then i'm going one go ahead
yeah
hans has a history point
hans is going to take your longest run
no he won't i'm not worried about that
he's three away
courage help me out man come on dude
what do you need wait why am i helping
you you're winning never won and hans is
gonna win if you don't help me right now
wait i could have done something damn it
i'm an idiot
or what no i just got those cards i'm
not a social media
uh what do you want
i need a hey dude i'll give you [ __ ]
um he's winning i'll give you a [ __ ]
a sheep of wood and a stone let him
suffer a sheep a wood and a stone
i don't need any of those things okay
for a single hay sheep wood and a stone
i don't want to trade
[ __ ] hate you so much
it's sort of gone okay next turn
i need one [ __ ] hate dude no don't do
it i won't do it i'm not doing it you're
close to winning bro this is what it
feels like to be in the lead
yeah get used to it oh my [ __ ] god
dude i hate you
i know if i trade him this he's gonna
win
don't do it don't do it
just wait till the roll the dice move
the mice nobody gets hurt
so close dude
so [ __ ] close
no hans i refuse to [ __ ] shut up
let's go man
all right i'm gonna [ __ ]
roll the dice here
my turn
[ __ ] hate you dude
six
yes
[ __ ] you once
that was the first six i've been able to
pick up from there
4
16
3
15.
isaan said hey i'll be there
does he know how to play
should i ask him that
who
no don't ask
assan
or as ridge calls him ison
like a car
by nissan
hey you hanging out with that isan
you want a sheep
this is hilarious
she's sure
don't no don't trade with him do not
don't [ __ ] he's got eight he has eight
points right now he has two [ __ ]
voices not that close to winning
dude
dude what about
for two sheep i don't have a sheep don't
do it now what's it i'll give you guys
yeah i'll give you that
oh wait i don't have that sheep because
i traded it the hell guys
your opponents are really letting you
wait
no
wheat
oh no you want wheat
yeah no don't do it don't do it don't do
it don't do it don't do it don't do it
wait a minute
do not wait for two weeks
uh no i'm good all right go ahead and
roll the dice
i should have said anything
nine [ __ ]
yes
i forgot i had this
silly from gareth
steal away thief boy the one scared to
win no one
you want we
don't have rock don't train him do not
trade him don't no i don't uh wheat in a
rock
for what don't for i need a rash i need
a rock
do you have a rock don't do it dude you
want to break don't [ __ ] do it no i
don't want to break
what
i don't i can't do anything with a brick
i should have played it before i rolled
oh yeah [ __ ]
god damn it yes
oh my
[ __ ]
oh
oh [ __ ]
oh my god okay hold on hold on hold on
[ __ ] you hans can i move this [ __ ] back
over here spread him [ __ ]
i'm afraid garrett's gonna win 2-4 i
don't think so no you can't there's no
way
oh
do you have to show the cards you played
right
no one wants you to win yours
i don't [ __ ] care dude vorak does
i thank you borac
anybody have a sheep
i have my turn
have you ever played this online yeah
it's not as good i don't know how to do
all the things
there's more you can do i mean i don't
know how to do the basic things
what do you mean like i don't know how
to do like some of the basic things that
you need to do
like i don't know the controls oh
are you done yes
wait did you make a
city you're at nine points
ten
are you done
me
i'd like to does anyone want to trade
she for the sheep for a sheet for a
sheep i don't have a sheep fur sheep
hershey
no
two of them
no i don't have it all right your puns
seven
two three four five six seven thank god
hey
gareth
wait
pat was wondering what the address is
hold on
um
here you type it in
you don't want that to go out online
here
uh look at the uh the google maps and
can you like find out the address
um
nine
that's more pointed at
but then if you don't have wheat then
you can't get it
another city
um
i'm gonna do this one
you have wheat
or you have wood or a sheep
no
i would
you don't have a sheet i want a sheep
though do not trade him
he's at nine point two four six you're
at nine points
seven
eight
you're assuming he has two victory
points yes
he has a bold assumption
uh ten
it's a correct assumption trade
break
[Music]
i have a brick i've won a sheep that's
it he doesn't have no one has a sheep
dude nope
don't worry come on man
dude you don't have a sheep come on
play the game come on give me a sheep
dude come on dawns give me one sheep i'm
not gonna please it wouldn't feel good
if you won that way
yeah i'm gonna feel like you actually
deserve it
i'm just gonna win four four of course
she's gonna win i hate him so much
i'm definitely gonna win
are you gonna win on this turn hans yeah
i [ __ ] hate you so much i hope so are
you done yeah
are you really good i don't know seven
year old [ __ ] is nine fine
i [ __ ] hate you so much
i [ __ ] hate you so much
buddy that would have won me the goddamn
game dude i just couldn't help you
i didn't have any sheep
and why was that a night
no
okay i win
you have two victory points i told you
i [ __ ] told you to build a city right
i [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i [ __ ] hate everything so you still
have number one
dude yeah thanks way to bring that up
that's kind of funny
that's super funny
i got four cities
if you oh my god dude i hate you so much
honey
all right well
wait a second's on his way yeah let's
let's take a commercial break should i
stick around for a song yeah
i gotta go to i gotta get up
patenting the is
okay well we i don't need you guys then
in a good way you can get on your phone
and talk
pat asked for the
pat asked for the address
i know i said please
okay peace man
we should continue
yes
it's nice to start early that's for sure
start early lose early
yourself dude
i just can't ever get like decided
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right now it's live okay
oh okay david do you want to hit this is
this it's cbd oh it's just your video
oh is he yeah is he some good weed
yeah that's it yep that's it it's it's
great so it's all welcome to the future
this is
up soon oh [ __ ] you got this to the end
of the lease that's pretty awesome man
there's a nice place
you got it once at least
come up yeah february
unnecessary i don't know where it is
though really
oh it's there
that's why this is why that is why thank
you sir
very much
what is it what is the expansion like
is it a bigger board or same board yes
though this is the expansion right now
oh this is this is that oh there's two
there's two dead spots now there's two
different types of other expansions you
can do pirates or you can get uh
cities and settlements
and then that adds more rules to the
game it gets a little more complicated
okay
so this is dylan sullivan
from whitetail with david spring
nice to meet you
got to perform at the paramount it was
[ __ ] awesome man yeah
that was [ __ ] sick dude with david i
saw that [ __ ] this fun time i did
wow look at this gay muslims
yeah that'd be pretty good
do we want to do the rolling
let's roll away the rolling of giants
that's the ball
oh yeah i look like ahead of that it's
not really bad but
would have been great if you just came
out on paramount just did the lights out
with david's band material
you may have seen me
you know david spain right
you heard this guy
amber's new guru
hotel transylvania transformation
okay go
11. wow
this is this
different number yeah okay these roll 11
yeah seven
no it's usually pasta
it's strange how it uh
oh that's great
two sixes baby
[Music]
nine nine what the [ __ ] why you guys
were all rolling high numbers
two
yeah you just rolled snake guys yeah
and one looks like a lot isn't the truth
can you put that in the box damn damn
last seven well that's actually a good
position because then i get two in a row
right yeah yeah okay that's actually
nice well actually it's either haunter
eye that's gonna go yeah uh blast so why
eleven because it's coming because
i was
i thought so too
damn well then
that was a roller coaster of emotion for
me right there
oh i'm not
that was a roller coaster just get your
way buddy it's gonna be a long ride
right now
[Music]
we have just only begun
you son of a [ __ ] dylan
yeah how dare you choose the clearly the
best spot on the board
[Music]
so by far and away the best bottle just
for that i'm not rolling any six
oh there's some other good spots there's
a lot of good spots yeah there's a lot
here
i like these spots now
let's see
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
oh my god what happened to this
you know what the [ __ ] happened
you guys have been [ __ ] this
are you have to oh you had scores on the
floor
yeah
i'll have to redo it yeah and do you do
you change do you switch the camera
angles and stuff yourself
yeah
so i could do this
wow
or i could just make it smaller usually
i just put it
like right here
wow that's pretty good
and that way when i reach out
onto the board let's come from my side
sort of
that's cool messed up
oh my phone i was wondering i was like
that is a really cool setup it's a great
setup thank you
it was all pretty easy
yeah like streaming is pretty intuitive
when you start doing it yeah
the software is really it's really easy
yeah the software is good
all right gareth i know i know
you guys want to make this interesting
everyone put in 5 000.
enough with this [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god dude
that'll make it quite interesting
don't look at you
mr folgers
yeah you're right what
oh guys
this happened
that's a great spot
how did you [ __ ] that up dude
that's what was way better
somebody numbers
whatever you say man hey
i'm just saying you add up these dots
same element you do the math so you have
to like you gotta figure you gotta
spread yourself out you can't trap
yourself with just wood one man
one game dylan got like all the rocks
and then the rock part and then he won
just with all rocks
that makes sense
that are that
are you talking tracks
so there's lots of different strategies
yeah everyone's got their own
that's pretty cool
i might just go for development cards
usually rock weak sheep
the longest road is also a good battle
good god so many wars fought over the
long road
i remember the road
god damn this actually
largest army is that development cards
yeah development cards
riley's hopefully
can you text riley uh gareth yeah
[Applause]
i can't
so were were you being sarcastic about
cbd
yeah no we are not
of course you're not
no
isn't it sad that we have to do that for
you
yeah
what are you talking about
wouldn't it be ideal if we don't have to
do that
you guys i'm just such jokesters i swear
what the [ __ ]
y'all talking about what's going on here
you're still doing it
uh whose turn is it right my turn come
on hans i just turned away too yeah i
took the action i took
rock
silence we need silence on the court
um so
what did you guys uh do any cool shows
today
[Music]
actually the biggest game i've ever seen
at a parlor did you or twice really yeah
okay
damn
that's cool
opposite i enjoyed your set
oh
yeah just yelling
guitar guy i think i was so he turned it
up i swear right right because he was
empty he had no one listening to play
music across the street he had like at
least 30 people
and he just turned his guitar up i'm
like [ __ ] you bro that's dirty that's so
funny
hold an [ __ ]
no that room's always pretty good man
does uh i've been sleeping on it it's uh
does she uh she wasn't even there
tonight
she usually runs it though doesn't she
oh with jimmy though that's right that's
right
well i went to jimmy's mic on thursday
that one's always really good
or at least has a people there it's not
if it's not good there's at least people
there
huh
kind of reminds me of the do you guys
ever do the hooters
off of hollywood where they would spark
people in yeah
they're doing a good job of barking
people and have poor choices that's what
they're doing a lot of people just come
up
it's good for you
oh yeah that's something
[ __ ]
just gotta go for the sheep
[ __ ]
which way is
uh
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
oh sorry
what happened to that little
uh condiment container of wheat that i
had
oh man
i like pack the bowl a lot
what
what
nothing
this is so weird
are you freaking out right now like do
you know what
you're gonna do
no
no idea what you're gonna do we're gonna
be here for a couple hours
oh that's right all right god damn it
serpentine it's gonna take so much
longer to get to me i thought it was
hell
yeah i have no [ __ ]
idea what i'm going to do now
what are the rules on where you can put
a house
or
two
god damn it
it has to be two spaces yeah it can't be
right next to it so it can be so like no
well no
but if this wasn't there then you could
put it here okay
hey son uh your move sucked um
[ __ ]
those are that's a pretty essential
place to have both deserts that's kind
of crazy
yeah to have the both deserts like that
if we just put took away that one sheep
land it'd be a great desert
so we just added them together
[Music]
that way the game lasts a long time
i know you do that
[Applause]
rainy street's such a difficult place to
do comedy at
unless you're indoors
they have a stage in the back
yeah and they don't use it
i walk back there i'm like what are we
doing right now
yeah it's just it's a nice stage too
it's like in the round and everything
you want to do it for people and they
want like people walking by to be like
oh let's go walk let's go watch honestly
it'd be easier to bark people in if you
said there's a comedy show out back
because they're not going to see the
comics up there bombing
yeah wander back buy a drink yeah and
it's more private it's more protected
also people here in austin are
super excited about comedy so they'll
come to your comedy show
it's the same
[Music]
hans where's your bathroom in around the
corner
oh
i didn't even see that was open but
no tell me dylan what do you want to do
do you can tell me i'm not about to
place a settlement well if i'm for you
and don't take this
any certain way
do you leave in magic
if you do that i promise i'll roll only
12.
is this riley it's the police dude oh
they knew we were smoking the cbd
[ __ ]
yeah you can take that you can take my
spot eventually
[Music]
and you guys can scoot a little forward
look on this oh it's sand
we're at the beach
uh the girl that owned it probably was
nice
what does
she what are your shoes in a sandbox
thanks man
such a nice comfortable seat
it's like
takes me back to malibu
is that the beach
no
what mountain is that
i thought was like a pleasure i mean
there's pride
that's true
that is so true
that's where
the elites play oh [ __ ] we're gonna have
to back in there i won't leave again
this is like one of those puzzles where
you have to like move the pieces around
with the car part
to make a picture in the end but you
can't like pick up the pieces
oh yeah i like the card thing
yeah i was thinking the card thing first
too
okay it's like when you have to take a
fox and a hen and a bag of grain across
the river and you only have
oh yeah that's that one's like it's
super long right what you have to do
yeah
you're right you have to make this
five trips wow
you had the perfect opening you missed
it did you [ __ ] tell me dude where oh
you're really straight [ __ ]
yeah
yeah one of each yeah
god i'm baking we got two bricks
good crunch
nice try
oh yikes
oh my god i'm baking how long have you
guys been playing for jam
about an hour yeah
we've just been waiting
for gareth and i haven't played for
three hours really yeah
hershberger was here earlier okay
there's a whole different group of
people here
have you been streaming all the time
yeah
you can watch to see what you missed
damn just watching this happen
12
14 actually
hell yeah 14 14 year olds
cool
ouija board call upon bob saget let's go
gareth is the one that looks like tucker
carlson
who said that
who said that which 14 year old said
that i'll beat him
i'll beat you up brad that's sort of
funny though
yeah i feel i feel like gary lives in
like
1990. i think he's always been the cbd
he thinks that people watching us online
are all 14.
a lot
i'm also wearing uh
whatever this texture is he's pretty mad
this is pretty 90s honestly
dude you're such a 90s guy
only 90s kids will get gareth yeah
oh it's a bold move when he does it but
i'm just a [ __ ] idiot whenever i do
it is that it yeah [ __ ] you david what
is this [ __ ] dude okay already in
his head yeah
dude i'm gonna get you i've already beat
one person at the table
says gareth led the last game then
choked
how did i choke you can't choke and dawn
brad dude yeah hey you can absolutely
choke in a competition yeah that is the
nature of competition no it's a lot
there's a dice thing
so dylan starts us off
yeah the game's gonna be nice
good luck boys
seven
hit the ground running
dude
it's just if santa ponte gets excited
that you don't get seen
your goal is to keep santa funty calm
good luck i got a lot of sugar today
oh no oh my god
i have a wet rag so that'll be good
all right
five baby
six
baby
damn i can't do [ __ ]
man dylan got two rocks two orders yeah
that was quick
i'm in the worst position because i'm
gonna wait the longest i am 10 i'm in
the worst position i don't get to play
good spot no one likes a sour picture
you can't take wood for that one
because it's black
that's right
okay
oh you had another 10. i didn't see it
nice you try to catch us you try to
catch uh pat doing a santa fonte
[Laughter]
you put two you picked up two bricks
they're stuck together
rich has sticky fingers hey sticky
fingers over here
four
fingers
[Laughter]
oh man and uh oh do if i want to do
something do i have to do it before my
roll or can i do it now before yeah you
have to do it after you roll okay so i'm
going to build a road real quick
i'll add on to this
you just put it back on them
and then yeah
okay
five
five
oh
all right and
then i'm going to
buy a development card right it's cheap
sweet thank you rock right
shapes
yeah do you want the little menu yeah
that's
it you can get one more menu
can you get a menu
did i get a water
are you serious do you want water yeah
okay who else owns water
also
three waters
i think we'll start with the sashimi
why are you giving this
[Music]
hell yeah dude
i forgot my gareth jersey at home oh
dude the fact that you even had one
meaning
three people
you hurt yourself
straight from the tap
[Music]
uh
do you want a warfare tree or a sheep
for a shrimp
his old rock strategy god damn it it's a
six
here we go i have an alt rock strategy
basically where i just go
and then listen to like the lumineers
as a german girl for a number apparently
it's nine nine nine nine nine nine
wow
wow you came up with that right there no
i didn't
also it's not even my joke
i saw it on a forum
i didn't think of it just now and it's
someone else's shoes
that was a waste of time
well like i yeah i should have waited a
little bit until you guys like forgot
about garrett that's not that
wait what
did i do that yeah dude oh [ __ ] oh bad
[ __ ] bad what are you doing here
oh do you oh no i'm good yeah i'm done
okay
oh
[ __ ] you gotta re-roll watch your
sleeves he's pulling something funny
right here
you gotta re-roll both
clean it up dude
three three
oh
well i'm your [ __ ] that turn
[ __ ] you hans
and get [ __ ] that turn
[Laughter]
another road
oh man
um it's riley we're really rooting for
fives to be ruled right now
five oh baby let's go
i don't know
it won't happen again i'll guarantee it
okay i guarantee it
does anyone need
i'll do that
what for a week yeah
this is why he never joined isis
all right this game is gonna be debbie
yeah
yes
anyone want sheep
yeah what do you need sushi for two wood
i don't have one i can give you ore
can you give me a job at oracle
it's actually a very easy job to get
oh yeah
three
you could just apply
why don't you do it i should
[ __ ] will you
i'll do two for one it's not your turn
again
okay what you have rock
yeah you want sheep yeah i want one
sheep
sheep is actually really good
good
like shawarma
and he's
yeah until i get enough 11
for dev cards
what do people eat
then dylan be on the revenge i'm gonna
play my night
card and then put it on the six
all right do you have any it'll work for
now enjoy not having a card
that's what you get for making bad
choice [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] dude you know what
you know i'm just stopping you right now
before you get ahead of steve
six
seven
that's a seven that's five of those two
all right all right
i'm gonna get rid of four
that sucks
see if i would have taken a card from
you i would have been [ __ ] so this is
yeah blessing in the sky blessing in
disguise
wait what the [ __ ] oh god damn it he had
to remove the rock god damn it yeah he
rolled the seven yeah i know he's gone
through the road
you used a knife for that
i saw do you have to get that by the uh
i was trying to stop him before he even
got started
oh
yes
not a good move actually that's a good
move why why why it doesn't block me no
box me though
yeah it's still from a saunder
nine
that doesn't mean anything it's the
second most valuable number
[Applause]
third i guess third six eight nine
two
five
six eight nine five ten yeah
all right i'm gonna play a real builder
are you
uh you think you're going to lose again
god did i'm going to leave in the next
30 minutes are you going to place two
yeah one
that's this
[Music]
nine
wow oh
[ __ ]
god damn it build a road
why
does anybody need wood
i know you do
i'll do a
wood for hay or sheep anyone needs it
not that turns on
five nine
god
damn it
just leave the box over there
six
cool all right
on
nine this is ten
this is slightly less valuable stuff
whatever
god
[Music]
you want to have a war i have a wheat or
a brick to trade
i'll take that for uh the
thank you
[Applause]
you can just not give someone something
hey junior
and you know i just really hope hans
doesn't win that's all i have i don't
have any cards
yeah dude gareth you suck
like really hard about this
so who's the most eligible bachelorette
in austin come on
i
um
audrey scott is dating jamie gravy
you son of a [ __ ]
i'm glad you stopped being gay yeah did
you get rid of happiness
god give a name
yeah he's great he's got that commercial
with martha stewart too does anybody
want to trade
a partner with martin martha stewart and
did like a song about him wanting to
[ __ ] her for these like microwavable
it's very training it's amazing yeah
he's a funny guy i don't have anything
i love this stuff don't i need a wood
i'll give you a week for you i don't
have a one like he's like
i don't have one
yeah he's got like a really cool
character he turns over
they're both just
i got a five
[Applause]
metaphors for yeah yeah they're both
wearing the exact same thing
they both kind of have the same haircut
too we're like ish yeah yeah
it looks like yeah does anyone need
sheep
i don't care i need wheat
all right
seven
damn it dude put on his line honestly
you can do what you want sorry darling
oh man that that city
has power
dude dylan has a great spot to put a
city on that's 9 13 points
or 13 dots
i don't like all these conspiracy
theories flying around
i'm the q a of katana yeah
okay
yes
what
are you looking at so
i'm gonna take one from you give him a
straight why dylan no
you're gonna take his hands
right yeah yeah
i'm taking one from you why
because i chose you you have something
you have cards yeah you're [ __ ] son
of a [ __ ]
no no you can't you move you did you
having one of you shifted you son of a
[ __ ] you take this god damn it yeah do
you mean this is what i was going for
and you move your hands you took the
phone no you were moving that one into
my hand relax buddy
bastard
okay who's that
yeah you're definitely in the lead right
now
[Music]
oh
i haven't gotten anything this whole go
around well done um
all right okay no answers riley if you
get eight gold
six
i can't do anything i don't have any
cards
[Applause]
four
okay
okay
yeah
um does anyone have any
more i do sure what do you want
um
you have a word i got a wheel or a brick
ticket it's [ __ ] gone
if anyone has or i have we or brick too
good
you have wheat
one for one sure
thank you
you just wanted to trade with him
instead of cameron
i just didn't have anything
i didn't have anything unfortunately
again i'm good girl all right let's see
let's see
well
give me that sheet baby
all right 12.
[ __ ] you david
taking that wheat damn
six
um does anybody want to trade the brick
for a wheat
uh what
do you have i need a week i'm not sure
no
no
okay my turn [ __ ]
yes oh
it's a dragon knife
yeah
wow another
this is salted [ __ ] up
sorry no i don't think so you just
aren't looking like there's been like no
eight so
that's the issue
yeah i guess
i guess it'll come
yeah sure right love averages says the
april the 8th becoming a fury in a
second yeah
luckily david built
four roads
yeah david david is the longest road guy
huh
don't take the board hans whoa
three
and turn over
time
[Applause]
four
all right
this game is about as fun watching as it
is playing
oh david got a city most of it is
watching even when you're playing and i
will also
this is very true
does anyone need any brick for wood
okay and i would just need one
and i'll take longest road as well
actually
getting the longest road initially
initially yeah right
it's very early
it is two turns around i haven't got a
single card
okay i'm going to
hell yeah
bills
can i not just like
get a moment of space
it's got three development cards
are you done
boom seven
getting one car
let me take from dylan
you're exactly seven again
there you go
[Applause]
nine oh you got me on
let's see
does anyone need to break our sheep i
need a war
all right wait wait
break her sheep
um you know i'll do it for uh a brick
cool
thank you
do you think there was ever an ore war
there had to be
carrots i'm good all righty
let's go go
four wow of course
constantly
all righty guys boy it's doing good
build a
three
good job okay hey go [ __ ] yourself hans
and does anyone want to trade for brick
or anything you need a brick
actually you know what um i should just
save my [ __ ] i'm gonna end my turn
it's best
[Applause]
10 10.
nice
so uh how about the creek mics
no
they called me up i didn't sign up they
called me up i was like i'm not doing
this
i have feelings though
what about you go up there and just like
do comedy for like two like
drunk people
that are on stage
i thought it was fun
i guess it was a four-hour mic
it was what
it wasn't for four
today that's this game oh [ __ ]
does anybody need bricks
no
wait where's the what it got rolled five
oh
nobody needs any bricks
you're like a dad
works out there
all right excited
to do this i'm building roads
jesus christ dude [ __ ] your roads
are about getting more
resources is that part of the magic kind
of cornered with
with the dice numbers right now i'm
getting his brick and mortar and no one
will trade with me
i do like that
just put it right all right
and he has to give other kids stuff
never have a child of his own
oh fine
yeah you just got it there's deeper cars
the gold mine
a little bit look at that [ __ ] he's got
a city on two turns at a weak factory
hello hello
wow
watch out for him are you done yeah
you shut up david
five
oh
oh dude i forgot i get two
hayes cause i have the other set oh my
god what was i doing
this whole time
this time
[ __ ] okay
eleven
does anyone have a wheat and i'll give
him a brick or a sheep
i'll take a short break i'll do the
first sheet
he's next time
i know it's too much uh moving for you
the usa versus canada
in the who can be fattest competition
um i swear to god
wow okay i'm going to build a city
one
two
one two
two brick
what the [ __ ] do i have
does anybody have anything to say
[Laughter]
um i think the scene is really good and
i think that uh it's cool that we get to
play a part of this historic moment and
hopefully joe rogan's club opens up soon
yeah
for sure
it is really cool
is he gonna have pizza
tacos
i'll go there just for that
eight
you know
thanks man
but you're not allowed to sell game me
no yeah because then there'd be a market
for it and then people would go out and
kill elk
to uh
and then they'd kill all the population
oh that's why they do yeah that's right
i think
that's i think it's the reason
yeah that's why they don't serve like
venison a lot
in restaurants
because otherwise we would damn you got
another city
so like it's basically every meat we eat
like farmed
like seafood even pretty much now yeah
that's so why well if you like go to
central market like their [ __ ] is farm
but they farm it in the sea
like they have like these giant [ __ ]
nets which is crazy to think about they
can they keep them
like a bunch of fish in in the bay area
in the sea but it's so technically like
feed them and suffer
but it's kind of controlled like they
they do come by and they like you know
throw out like special phobias
pat we were in those showers too
he's just been going for big fat
and [ __ ] this guy
the jews
all right one more then we'll be good
or pat just thought it was a regular
train
why is everyone like scared
he doesn't say a word the whole trip
it's the quietest jew
[Laughter]
yeah it's actually not that bad in here
are you done does anybody need or
wheat or
brick a
for a sheep
i have a sh you have a shape i need a
sheet
which one do you need or wheat or uh
brick go with or
real man of the economy right now
good save
yeah there's these two too with the
sevens all night yeah
so
oh my god one two three four
five six
two three four five six seven yeah seven
yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um
yeah let's call it
eight
all right riley so
i think i left you in good standing
you're leaving yeah i'm gonna take off
here let's see
i mean hey i kind of got used to not
playing
i do don't
don't do this
are you gonna come in or not i'll build
this yeah but i'll play from right here
okay it i don't think that matters we
have to do some mental gymnastics
you know actually
i
yep
to go to the little gym
you've been there
here's what i have done
what are you a child
my mom was like okay
oh sorry uh eight
all right good to see y'all
torch
right there oh beautiful peace out later
dude
yeah man thanks for the cbd
no problem
yeah no problem
sounds like it was a problem
anyone want
is
can you throw in my jacket that's on the
ground over there
no it's over there patagonia oh it's
right there so we still be running
before him
yeah
everyone got
everyone got less than seven or less
cards yes
yep
you had a discard huh no i didn't know
okay
there's basically no way i can win
though
[Music]
uh what are you
green
yeah
um
okay
dude
david's leading yeah
but just how
one two three four five six
very bad
um
um
okay
riley
yes
nice
oh [ __ ] it's an intruder
[Music]
okay here's a good pool
yeah
well there's nowhere else you could put
i gotta get on with it um and then
i'm playing tonight oh [ __ ]
let me do it again because i am just
stealing sure
uh
nine what do we think boys
you did a nine yeah you did it that's
six is beautiful
[ __ ] you
yeah
um
feels like
good job
yeah i'm going to score
huh you got five yeah
done
oh king square right there
[Music]
uh
yeah [ __ ] david again
i got eight points
i thought dylan would be more of a
threat no i did too but then david spent
the whole game going oh look at all the
things he has
meanwhile
america cultivating
his own plans
you guys left me all alone here on the
beach second
you guys trapped ourselves against each
other
whatever it's not over yet though
close to six
yeah who did that who did that
who's responsible huh
huh
wood or wheat
what are we
want some wheat
i can do i can do wheat okay
wood anyone fishy
wood
you're looking for
wood
okay
i'm gonna give you a two sheet for one
wood three sheets for one wood you're at
eight you're like dominating right now
who's behind the sheep that has five
woods
he's got all those guys you got all
those cards too
so much this game
um
i'm gonna use
monopoly
and i'm gonna do the
uh wheats
what does monopoly do
that's right baby until i die
okay
that's probably not great for the
podcast
what they can't hear it
they definitely can
whatever dude maybe they like it
do you guys like that anyone have a
sheep i have a wheat
yeah oh my god and i'm done
[ __ ] somebody run the tape back did he
actually pay for those
brought it back
that's right yeah look at what you got
would you guys rather have global
warming or sharknado
oh sharknado because it's seasonal
what are you eating
no there's uh there's actually always
one
bubble warning
but
i don't know tomatoes like
it's still your turn by the way
it's actually oh [ __ ]
uh
strategy
my god
wow dude this is a tough gig for me this
has been a very tough game for me too
gareth slash riley
also having a tough time
it's riley
a double dose of dill
watch out
nine
four four five eight three
four everyone's pretty much the same
except for david
we're gonna help pat build the road
here cut him off
i think longest road is kind of the
foreground conclusion here
he's got too much she's got so much
space on the air we can catch him except
maybe dylan
by what
you only you're the only one who has the
space to catch them
i mean i could make a ring one two three
four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve are
you just gonna build a bunch of brothers
right now
yeah you can hatch them
you could catch them i could
but you don't have anything
eleven's been rolled once this entire
year it feels like yeah i have the
shapes
if i get that port
he's still leaning
they're both the same okay
[Music]
what are you in those development cards
all right
sheep
got to be careful of dylan
oh yeah he's got he's got a she's got at
least a couple victory points in there
you think
yeah
sure because
that too well they're all nice
eight
i got this
i'm going to take
everyone's war
[Music]
oh no look at that [ __ ] you can exchange
there's at least four in there yeah that
was that wasn't that was nuts that would
be two big three points and probably
nights
worse things [ __ ] what is what a
complicated game between dylan and
centos yeah that's what it is
not really i think that's very those
monopoly cards are clutch i've never
gotten one of those
did you change a settlement into a city
is it just one more point
or two more points on your score one
more one
okay
let's see
then
okay
have you guys seen spider-man
no
you haven't seen it yet yeah
it's all right it was a fun break is fun
yeah
does he um in love with a girl spiderman
yeah her name is girl man
[Music]
that's the name of the stripper
she's from thailand
um
oh i was like
i should have a transgender superhero
trans
i man the power of being annoying
your office meetings will get longer
and the power of restructuring
business i guess
ralph he's a villain who identifies as a
hero
yeah
well that was trans this is this is
that's a trans hero trans character
did anyone see wreck-it ralph 2
oh yeah that might be better
do you wanna just put it there i don't
even know
i don't know what he's trying to do
i have no idea
maybe you can build it right here
fine i'll put it over there jesus right
here
yeah that's better it's definitely it's
a better strategy
it's just all fives from here now
you don't need them
matter
[Music]
scent of
manta
and
yeah
boy
really want to have these dev cards
really
go for it
there's someone doing every strategy
there's someone doing longest roads some
of the largest army someone doing
development cards someone
losing
um
has anybody said anything about me
uh people say you're low energy
really
yeah
how much longer do you think those are
so it's good to hear
what does it say
read the chat every once in a while
you know they want to be a part of this
too
dude my god
building out of 678 was a mistake
that was a great spot
these guys
four five four eleven
a great spot
does anybody need wood
no
have you guys been into the woods
yeah for a sheep
isn't that
so if you put the three
wood down for uh
i'll put two wood down
my numbers
[Music]
i'm good actually
road
uh settlement
and my turn
thank you
got 11.
that's a surprise
said i predict this cookie will be
really stale
dude
they should have predicted the joke was
gonna be stale as well
whole thing that's what you took
someone said that
i got wheat
i can't trade with you
are you sure you can
i'm good
[Music]
like
emperor palpatine when he was young
what is it eleven no that's ten my bad
teen
god damn it must be fun to be david it
always picks up cards
short
[Music]
i really thought i would have my work
cut out with
oh i'm aware yeah i built on a six and
an eight and i've picked up a card in
almost three turns
this [ __ ] is the worst
anyone got a
wheat
yeah what are you getting on
i'll give up
a brick
oh funny that's kind of global warming
happens
eight
six
four
dylan's five
i got two more points yeah he's at six
oh yeah
dude come on you can do
it oh
so close
let's try this one
[Music]
[Music]
um if he doesn't roll a seven on himself
here
he doesn't even notice
um
all right i'm gonna be a minute
you're gonna what be a minute
you guys want to do one more after this
i definitely yeah
[Music]
yeah you had three
um
it was enough
it never corrected for the six of these
it never corrected you just stayed at
the fives and 11's and 10.
wow it's colder over here than it was in
the bathroom
i kind of want to go back to the
bathroom
it's the icy coldness of a group of
people that don't really like you
that's not like online or offline
one two three four five six seven eight
and
damn
yeah
all right today for
jesus wow
well this is really tried all right i'm
done
so he definitely has nine points yeah
yeah yeah
you don't breathe like that with eight
points
five
let's go
this was a crazy game insanity
dylan went out to an early lead then
sent to fonti
took the lead yeah redundant this was
the
best spot right here
these guys so much
that's nine
it was not supposed to find available
what
he's trying to get messy
i feel like i got pretty good odds
yeah it's all more than half shoes
um
i'm gonna do
two wood for one sheep
oh damn there's still wind
uh no that's gonna be [ __ ]
hey
[Music]
whatever i'm done
three and a half rows someone needs to
train me some [ __ ]
no seven
oh god
wow dude you [ __ ] us both
how many is it half
if you have how many
over seven so if you're seven you're
okay yeah
one two three
um i'll try to do my dick
i'll try my rock for your seat
changing my work for your feet
i'll treat you
five dollars if i could [ __ ] your sheep
okay anyone want sheep
i could use some sheep rick
i can only do i can only do wood how
many points are you at
what
i'll give you uh brick for a sheep i
didn't put this down yet
brick i need brick to be santa fonte i
won't i mean i probably won't even do it
okay i can give me two more roads and
two more bricks you need two more bricks
yeah
put that hole with that there would be
another one
for five six seven i need me i need two
more rows and two more bricks
four bricks two row two woods
what are you having three sheep
okay to these that's a fantastic what is
this [ __ ] i need two more roads woods
too for uh oh well don't do that if you
can't have it
two more wood i'm using i could
definitely do two wood for two sheep uh
can i do four brick for one sheep twist
give me the other sheet i'm gonna give
me more cards okay fair
yeah
what is wrong with you guys
that's five right
up to the lead
you just
conspired against
three
because you're so far behind that you
just haven't done this
you can just simply
well that doesn't work
that does one two three four five six
seven eight nine one two three four five
six seven eight
bro
give me that [ __ ]
all right i'm done i don't think this is
legal
coming up here like that
because you connected here we got a
knife
how can you connect here and then go
this way no it's not connected it's
totally unconnected you got to think of
do you connect here to the this is the
start so one two three four no this was
the start this was here this one and
then this one how is that it doesn't
matter when you put the world down it's
just the longest road that you
continuous road you can make
i defeated the jew with the circle
you didn't move this when it was seven
who did it you didn't you rolled the
seven and you never moved it but it's
too late now i don't remember that
oh that's right
just left behind you
do you want this wood backpack no pads
does anyone want a wood for an ore
this is a class game or not
or
or
no
you want one yeah
despite eating
it it's frustrating
i mean you just have to build two more
roads
whoever's orange needs to cut him off
here i have nothing
and oh you're you you go after him
anyways yeah i'm done
i'm stuck at where i am
okay i'm good i'm just here to play
spoiler
thank you for helping me [ __ ] over santa
fonte that fell off for a little bit
yeah well now now my next goal is to
[ __ ] over i guess
i don't think i don't think i can
five
dude five
let's go
five
go through that one
i think you can go
wait dude i thought it was my turn it is
oh that was a tweaker that was a tweet
oh sorry sorry sorry i put it back it
was on the six okay
i'm so sorry just the order finally
messed me up
yeah
um anyone got any rocks
i'm going to ask you for what do you get
what do you give it up
like sheep or something
i'll do a rock for two weeks
two weeks for two rocks
uh yeah maybe i can't wear it
turn three yeah
it's already three o'clock out here is
it yeah it's awesome
okay
he built two
put two on the board
on me it's on my tab
yeah
what did
he don't worry about it bro
but it's uh your tripod
what did you roll
a five
oh i don't i think i lost right then
yeah
eleven
here
please let him roll a seven
uh
um
it was like the same number of turns to
win
because he went first so
how many points what did you have you
had two victory points i had two and
then i was trying to get the row seven i
have two grand can you play
good drop you literally got the order to
build it for me
i had a or already
like but yeah
it's just a little flex little flex yeah
cause i already did it so i wanted
to go it's three it's 3am
good game boys yeah that was awesome
thank you guys so much for tuning in
um
i'll see you guys later
everyone left